that because the woke thing is so out of
control and because two plus two is five
and boys are girls and if you're not
racist you are racist because everything
is so backwards when everything's
backwards people need something to fall
back on and I I can feel this I can feel
it and I mean I thought I was an atheist
five or six years ago I'm not anymore
I'm a Believer I toured with Jordan
Peterson he moved me on some on probably
the most important question of of all
you know in essence
um I think a lot of people are going to
go that direction it's it's a sad state
in a way because because liberalism in
its truest form should be able to stand
on its own but but the left has
destroyed liberalism
change things so that words have no
meaning anymore and then people will go
to religion I'm actually not saying that
religion is bad I I'm not saying that at
all actually I think at the end
society's somehow need an organizing
principle and I don't know that there is
one better than belief at some level uh
but I I completely agree with you and
are you you're Jewish you go to Temples
where do you go
um you know it's funny I I've sort of
come back towards it Dennis Prager
actually helped me a lot on this he ran
in La he he's not a rabbi technically
but he was running services and runs
sort of like a it's sort of like a
misfit Temple and I started going and I
you know I Dennis has been a mentor and
a friend and everything else and he
brought me back to a lot of that but you
know for Jews I'm sure it's somewhat
similar to you it's become more of a
culture and a way of thinking and a
sense of humor and holy [ __ ] we survived
somehow 5 000 years of this lunacy and
there's still a couple of us left so but
I am trying to figure out how that
pieces into my life regarding regarding
Church religion
ultimately what we're talking about I
think is just a bigger sense of purpose
and meaning in life ultimately we're all
just trying to figure out what the hell
are we doing here we're like how what is
life what is the meaning of life and
I mean look at the stats the most common
religion now is
non-believer yeah right so God has been
taken out of society and I'm not
religious law but I I will say that I do
and this might just because of my
upbringing and my mom you could do
whatever
and like a typical Jewish mom but for
most people in America they don't have
necessarily a higher sense of purpose or
meaning and kova has exacerbated that
you're stuck at home alone you lost your
job you don't know what's going on
you're taking opioids you're you're
looking at everyone on TV and on social
media everyone's doing amazing and
you're just stuck in this you know
shitty life and
if you're if there's nothing to cling on
to for religion what do you have and a
lot of people cling on to politics you
know especially even on the left these
days but that's true that's why you have
to give the woke credit because they
turned a political ideology into a cult
you cannot get out of that cult it's why
so many of them go so crazy why is Jon
Stewart right now
screaming about white people all the
time it's because he went into the woke
thing and then once you're in it Jon
Stewart knows he's a hundred million
dollar white guy middle-aged white guy
in essence right so he has to keep going
otherwise they'll turn on him too it's a
religion that you cannot leave and he's
what you would call and I learned this
term literally from you Dave Rubin a
classic liberal he should be truly I I
don't think he's in his true head I
don't think he's a crazy woke leftist
right but just I don't know that
anyone's watching he's gone down that
path yeah he's doing Bill Maher avoided
that and stayed true to himself I mean I
do this on my show all the time so
frustrated with Bill Maher I really am
yeah I'm supposed to be why are you
frustrated because he's so freaking
close he's so damn close to getting it
and then he just shoots himself in the
foot yes so so Bill Maher he gets it on
critical race Theory now he got it on
kovid finally two years too late but he
got it he gets it on the gender stuff he
gets it on free speech he gets all the
big ones but until you're willing to say
I will not support and vote for people
who have ushered this all in then you're
then at some point you're no longer
doing a service right right it's one
thing to wake so you ask me before where
we started was about waking people up
and how do we move people well Bill
Maher I guess at some level he's woken
up some liberals right so that that is
good and by the way this is a guy who
I've loved and admired for for 20 years
but at the end because of trump
derangement syndrome and his Bingo by
the way Trump broke him to the point
that you can't you can't say I'm against
critical race Theory I'm against all the
gender stuff and then it's like all
right bill so when it came down to it
would you have voted for Glenn young
International and if the answer is no
you would have voted for Terry McAuliffe
then you actually aren't at the end of
the road yet so he's getting people
almost to the promised land and right
when they get to the promised land
they're right there the Border he then
takes them the other way so last week
you probably saw it he sat on a show he
said that the Republicans would love if
there were no black supreme court
justices
uh you know there is a black Supreme
Court Justice and he's a conservative
did you know that bill and everyone
loves him and I guarantee you and yeah
he's an Uncle Tom and I guarantee you
that every conservative in the country
would love if there were 12 of him yeah
so at the end you get there and then all
you got left is but their race I think
his problem actually is that he's called
So Many religious people crazy for 20
years that he's back it's very hard for
him to put that together how special
called religious list it's not like yeah
but let me tell you exactly what's
happening with him because I'm living it
yeah I got it I got it he's going down
the road he's going to the path you said
he gets to the Pearly Gates and who's at
the gate bro it's Trump so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]